vamos a repasar un poco lo que ya
sabemos acerca de las leyes de los
exponentes si nosotros tenemos por
ejemplo 3 esto elevado a la potencia
número 2 ya esto lo multiplicamos por 3
esto a su vez elevado a la potencia
número 3 entonces que obtenemos bueno
pues es que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que 3 elevado al cuadrado lo podemos
visualizar de la siguiente manera como 3
por 3 ya esto lo estamos multiplicando
lo estamos multiplicando por tres
elevado al cubo pero 3 elevado al cubo
lo podemos ver como tres por tres por
tres
ahora date cuenta que tengo 1 2 3 4 5
veces al 3 multiplicándose por sí mismo
por lo tanto puedo concluir que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 3 que 3 elevado
a la potencia
dos que son estos dos de aquí justos
estos dos de aquí en más
más
3 que son justo estos tres de aquí estos
tres de aquí de tal manera que esto me
va a quedar exactamente lo mismo que 3
elevado a la quinta potencia y si te das
cuenta esto es cierto porque aquí
tenemos cinco veces al tres
multiplicándose por si mismo estamos
diciendo que esto es cierto bueno pero
esto ya lo sabíamos ahora lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es pensar un poco y
que pensemos qué significa tener 33
elevado a la potencia y se me ocurre
menos 2 a qué me refiero cuando tengo al
3 elevado a la potencia menos 2 y bueno
nosotros podemos pensar bajo esta misma
perspectiva utilizando una suma de
potencias y de aquí poder concluir algo
acerca de 3 elevado al menos 2 piénsalo
por un momento
ahora qué te parece si nosotros hacemos
un pequeño experimento vamos a tomarnos
tres elevado a la potencia dos elevado a
la potencia 2 ya esto a su vez lo voy a
multiplicar por 3 elevado a la potencia
menos 2 que voy a obtener de esto bueno
yo sé que justo por esta misma propiedad
que tengo aquí arriba esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 3 elevado y las
potencias se suman elevado a la potencia
dos más antes me ponerlo con otro color
más a la potencia menos 2
- 2 ok y esto es exactamente lo mismo
que 3 elevado a la 2 más menos 2 estrés
elevado a la cero esto es 3 elevado a la
potencia cero y nosotros también sabemos
que hay una propiedad o una regla de los
exponentes que nos dice que todo número
todo número elevado a la cero siempre es
1 esto es igual a 1 ok y esto me va a
servir bastante porque entonces y déjeme
agarrar esta parte de aquí si yo tomo
justo esta parte de aquí estoy diciendo
que 3 elevado déjame copiarla y pegarla
que 3 elevado a la potencia 2 x 3
elevado a la potencia menos 2 esto es
exactamente igual
a uno esto es exactamente igual a uno o
dicho de otra manera y ahora puedo
agarrar este de aquí qué te parece si
divido todo voy a dividir todo tanto la
parte izquierda como la parte derecha de
esta igualdad entre 3 elevado al
cuadrado entre 3 elevado al cuadrado
esta parte la voy a dividir entre 3
elevado al cuadrado y la otra parte
también la voy a dividir entre 3 elevado
al cuadrado y déjame poner que estamos
dividiendo así que para esto voy a
hacerte aquí una línea y aquí otra línea
y ahora date cuenta que este 3 elevado
al cuadrado multiplica y a su vez
dividida y por lo tanto se pueden
cancelar este se puede cancelar con este
y me va a quedar un resultado
sorprendente que 3
elevado a una potencia menos 2 esto es
exactamente lo mismo es exactamente lo
mismo
uno que uno
está
dividido
dividido entre tres elevado al cuadrado
entre tres elevado al cuadrado y esto
está
sorprendente porque ya tengo una forma
de ver a tres elevado a la menos 2 que
es justo lo que nos preguntábamos hace
rato utilizando esta propiedad que tengo
aquí arriba de la suma de exponentes
utilizando una propiedad de los
exponentes que nosotros ya sabíamos
puedo concluir justo esta expresión que
tengo aquí que 3 elevado en la menos 2
es lo mismo que 1 entre 3 elevado al
cuadrado de este paso pase a este de
aquí y bueno nosotros podemos leer que 3
elevado a la menos 2 es exactamente lo
mismo que 1 entre 3 elevado a la versión
positiva de menos
y es justo lo que quiero ver en el
siguiente vídeo con mucha calma vamos a
demostrar que 3 elevado a cualquier
potencia negativa es exactamente lo
mismo que 1 entre 3 elevado a esa misma
potencia pero positiva su versión
positiva y para eso vamos a utilizar
justo lo que tenemos acá arriba y que ya
sabemos que cuando yo tengo una base
elevada a una potencia por otra base
elevada a otra potencia distinta con la
misma esto es exactamente lo mismo que
la base elevada a la suma de las
potencias y con esto voy a poder llegar
a una expresión equivalente para 3 o
para alguna base elevada a una potencia
negativa así que por este vídeo lo único
que te puedo encargar es que pienses un
poco más en el significado de 3 elevado
a la menos 2 hasta la próxima